Hey, what's going on? It's bill
bar and a, it's time for the, uh,
Thursday afternoon, Monday morning
podcast just before Friday. And I am
just checking in on you. How are you
guys doing? I you having a good day.
All right.
Day
vindication baby. Ah, fuck.
Finally. Finally shut. Nall
you sports. Sportsbar conch,
right the fuck up in the back of your
dumb fucking heads. You knew this was the,
you knew, you knew he
was innocent. You can't,
not even innocent. I'm just saying he
gives the whole fucking thing was so fun.
It was so fucking stupid. You
are pisses me off. Obviously.
I'm talking about the Tom
Brady decision here. Um,
which doesn't even say that he's innocent
of all the fucking deflate gate shit,
which pisses me off.
It's just says that the commissioner
didn't execute article 46 on a proper ran
or let the court date.
But I need a scalable whenever,
I guess article 46 has
to do with what the, the,
the steps to commissioner is supposed to
take when he fucking goes to suspend a
player. Evidently, I guess
I don't fucking know.
So basically they didn't have a fucking
case and he tried to fucking rubber
stamp his way through it. I
still, I can't believe it man.
I thought the court was going
to go inside with the fucking,
I really did, but fortunately
they didn't end. Um,
I dunno. I mean is happy as I am
that it's, it's over. What was,
it was a huge distraction to the team
and it was a big fucking waste of time.
And uh,
I actually saw on Twitter
another Boston guy, uh,
Donny Walberg goes, okay, now what
about all those draft picks we lost?
Which is a great fucking point that
I didn't see anybody else bring up.
Everybody's sitting at skipping down
the street cause Brady's going to be
playing, but we still got fucked
out of all those draft picks. Dude.
How successful are the Patriots that
they are getting fucked with to this
goddamn level?
How much of a bunch of fucking
babies is everybody in the,
not everybody,
but I'll the higher ups in the cults
organization grow a fucking Dick.
You lost a game to
fucking drag it through.
This whole thing make literally turned
it into fucking an episode of Falcon
Crest or dynasty. I'll go with dynasty. I
never watched either one of those shows,
but it always seemed like somebody was
getting thrown in a pool right there,
dress and makeup on whatever.
I've gotta be honest with you.
I don't even have any fucking,
I don't even give a shit if you're honest
with you. I don't even give a fuck.
Once I saw that he got four
games and then the fifth game,
when he was coming back, they were
going to be playing against the colts.
It was just like, is this like a
fucking soap opera? I don't know.
I got that same queasy feeling
when I used to watch the NF one.
I was watching the NBA in the two
thousands and I sit there telling
my friends, go on this game.
This game is fucking fixed.
And then that got to the point of saying
the NBA is fixed. And of course it was,
ah, you got your tin hat on. You're
fucking, you're a conspiracy theorist.
And what do they do?
They find a fucking mobbed up ref.
Who's throwing fucking games
and then I go, well, there
you go. I'm vindicated. Right?
And everybody's like, well,
it's just one guy. Oh
yeah. It's just one guy.
It's always just one guy. That
fucking Guy Oswald. Right.
It's always just one fucking guy,
Oliver north.
It's just why Ollie north, he put the
whole fucking thing to get. It's always,
it's always just one guy.
Yeah.
Let me tell you something.
If a,
if you're involved in something and you
don't feel like you're getting all the
information from your other fucking
criminals, just know that you're,
you're going to be the guy.
If Shit goes down,
you're the guy going to be left holding
the fucking bag. They always had that.
Any smart criminal fucking organization
always has the guy who's going to be
left holding the bag just in case.
Just in case the shit hits the fan.
Who's a bad guy?
All the north fuck.
And we said Oliver Stone, they're
fucking, what's his face there?
Old Shot in the gut.
Lee Harvey Oswald.
MMM.
And a whatever. I ain't want to, I can't
remember what my fucking point was.
Why would you listen to this shit?
I don't give a fuck.
I gotta be honest with you.
I thought that, uh, I gave,
I stopped giving a shit I think
like three months ago when they,
when I found out he was appealing it and
then he had to appeal it to the guy who
fucking suspended them. I'm like, Gee, do
you think he's gonna win this one? And,
uh, once they gave him a four game
suspension, I was just like, I, you know,
whatever. I was actually, I was the
guy going, hey, he shouldn't suspend.
He shouldn't appeal it. Just
take the suspension, become
a fucking martyr, rest up,
you're 38 year old bones
and come back and, and uh,
game five.
And I also thought there was no fucking
way that he was going to win it because
I read something where they said that
they usually side with the decision made
by the arbitrators. So, uh, I'm
whatever, I'm happy that it happened,
but I also don't really give a shit
who gives a fuck. You know what I mean?
It's,
it's a whole leaks become a fucking joke.
We've got a female ref that
got a female coach. Why?
Because they give a fuck about women.
No,
cause they're doing damage control
because of the ray rice thing.
They don't give a shit about women.
I give a fuck about anything. Right.
They give a shit about money.
So they're wearing pink for
an entire fucking month.
I don't even know what it
is anymore. Right. And Dude,
I called it as far as he would say.
So with all these concussions and all of
that type of shit and now they got all
the women coming into the NFL. I'm calling
it right now, within 10 to 15 years,
the combination of the damage
that this game does does,
and the female
mmm
intellect being brought into the game,
this dumb game.
That's awesome.
Where guys bash each other's brains in
will become a much more intelligent game
of flag football. I think that
that's what's going to happen.
They're gradually,
they're just getting rid of all
the dumb shit that makes men great,
which is hurting one another
in a competitive way.
They're going to get rid of all of it.
They fucking with hockey.
They got to get fighting at a hockey.
They're going to get a bunch of
women in the fucking, the NFL.
They'll start wearing pink
all four fucking months.
They'll have flags, you know,
maybe play a little two hand touch.
They'll start with offensive and
defensive lineman starting in the standup
position so they don't smash
into each other. And um,
and I dunno, then they'll have some new,
hey, hey, hey, take it easy fucking rules.
They'll just keep whittling away at it.
And in the end,
by the time I'm in my eighties,
the NFL and the NHL that
I watched will be like,
I used to go to the Roman Colosseum and
watch Christians getting thrown to the
fucking lions. But you know what? I got
to tell you this. It was a hell of a run.
Was there a hell of a run?
You know, they got all women,
uh, sports talk shows now.
Okay,
they're going to fucking
just through pressure alone,
whether they're good or not,
everyone's going to be so afraid of being
called sexist. They're going to those,
they're going to take over the
Terry Bradshaw, Howie long shows.
It'll be all women,
all women coaches.
It'll be all women all the
time wearing pink and it'll be,
it'll be a completely different
thank it's over.
It was a hell of a fucking run.
You know,
a lot of guys got hurt,
but a god damn it,
it was entertaining and now it's over.
So what are you going to do? It's a new
era. Just sit back and find that view.
Ah, fuck me. Good Lord. How
do you fuck up a good thing?
How do you fuck up a great
thing like that? Um, anyways,
I'm just giving the lady shit.
We all know the biggest lady out.
There's Jim or say Jesus Christ.
You know,
he's fucking fucking hide his face
right now behind a a little parasol.
Xe fucking runs into his office.
Twirling the thing crying. Yeah.
Fuck you
fucking baby fucking unbelief.
I have been holding my so bad.
Let's not talk about Jim or say,
let's just talk about,
let's just go fucking random here.
All right,
for all you patriot haters out there,
let's just say your next door
neighbor was a drug addict. Okay?
Who had a dead mistress and for some
reason he thought your fence was too much
on, on his side of the property, even
though you had a fucking God damn,
whatever. Yeah, that's what happened.
It's like you put a coat of paint on it
and that extra coat of paint because you
didn't strip it down to the, would you
put that extra coat of paint on it?
And that just started to creep in
end to the other guy's property.
Let's just say that.
Does your next door neighbor who's a drug
addict and as a dead mistress hires a
guy who isn't a doctor but says he is
one to build a case against you and let's
just say for some fucking reason
it's upheld and you stand to lose $2
million with any of that make any fucking
sense to you.
And furthermore,
when you appealed it and then
the entire thing got reversed,
wouldn't you just be like,
well yeah,
that's kind of what it took
the NFL seven months to do.
I feel um,
unfucking believable.
Unfucking believable.
Now, having said that,
I think it's going to be a hell of a
a year in the AFC east. I think. Uh,
I'm loving rex Ryan coming back
with the bills and he has a defense.
I think,
uh,
all the people that think
that he's learned something
from talking shit are, are,
are dopes. Uh, Rex Ryan
has not learned anything.
Rex Ryan is Rex Ryan.
All right.
And he's always going to be rex
Ryan and less he loses his defense.
Then he slumped his shoulders and tries
to act like he's a class act. He isn't,
I'm not saying he doesn't have class,
but he's not a quiet guy.
He said guy fucking talking with his
mouth full with spaghetti sauce on the
front of his shirt. That's just
two years. And you know what?
You need that fucking guy. You don't
want to look at him when he's eating.
But other than that, he's a
fun guy to have around. So I'm,
I'm predicting right now without
even looking at the schedule,
without even knowing a fucking thing,
I'm going to say that we split
with the bills and when the bills,
when probably when the first
one or whatever I am go,
I predict that a rex Ryan is going
to talk, not all kinds of shit.
He will make some sort of comment and
you will see that manic look on his face.
Um, it'll probably, I don't know,
I'll probably say something dumb
about one and this one of the Superbowl
or some stupid shit like that. And uh,
and as always,
Bill Belicheck will be looked at as
a dud as a guy who's a, you know,
socially inept and all that type of shit.
I love when people buy into the fucking
press wine in about that, you know,
fucking Bella check is a hot shit.
He's just smart enough not to talk
to those fucking cons in the press.
He knows that.
He says they're
going to twist around and it's just
going to be used as, as a, you know,
what do they call it?
Fucking bullet of board material.
Bill Bellacheck said this about you
guys, who does, who respect you.
That's why every fucking
week I don't give a shit.
If he was going to play a bunch of standup
Comedians, full pads, he still be like,
well, you know, any given Sunday anybody
can win. And uh, you know, you know,
the second day leave you fucking breaks
out a Stogie and a scotch, right?
Start just telling stories.
Um,
I'm just saying, all right, just
because somebody wrote it a set,
it doesn't mean it's true.
Do you know some asshole in Twitter?
I don't know if he's being an asshole.
He sent me a thing saying, hey bill,
you should go back to drinking
because according to this study,
uh,
you know,
taking time off from drinking does not
cleanse your liver and actually might be
detrimental to your health.
So I click on it, Click Bait.
Fuck it. I can't resist. I'm weak
mentally. I click on the shit, right?
We,
uh,
I go to it and I read and it's just some
woman talking to one doctor who just
says a bunch of vague shit
about like, if, you know,
if you normally drink or whatever,
if you would just to stop cold Turkey that
yet, blah, blah, blah, blah, Blah blue.
It was, so I just wrote back yet one
dope talks to one doctor, get the facts,
the whole article,
just,
it just reeked of being a study
funded by somebody who sells alcohol.
And he could see how when they
use the quotes from the doctor,
it was always like dot, dot, dot.
Something that guy said. Dot, dot, dot.
So they just take a little fucking clip
of it. He was probably doing that thing,
you know, where they say like, one glass
of wine every day is actually healthy.
And, uh, then they just, you
know, a cross examine, well,
let's say somebody was to stop drinking
that glass of wine and was to eat
McDonald's every day. Then would
that be a good, healthy thing?
And then the doctor's like, yeah,
well, you get all of that instance.
I imagine that, uh, you know,
if you were eating a hive
transfats food add, uh,
you did not have that
glass of wine that will,
I mean you would probably
be better off with the, uh,
your arteries being clogged
up by the Trans fats.
You probably want a little bit alcohol and
come in there, right. Uh, clean it out.
So at that point, yeah. Yes.
I would venture a guess that
that would be detrimental.
And then they take all of that shit and
then they just say, taking one glance,
you know, knocking off booze could be
detrimental. Give me a fucking break.
I know I don't need a goddamn
study to tell me that.
Taking a fucking 70 days
off from drinking is,
is is good or bad for my liver.
I see the results.
I did a Gig with Versie
like in the beginning of May
and he came walking in his
skin look amazing space.
It came at oh first he was glowing.
He goes, do it. Been crushing it.
I haven't been, I haven't drank
in five days. I'm like, dude,
I can see it in your face.
Your face is already thinner and it look,
your skin looks clear.
I've got to look at some fucking study.
Now look,
I'm not saying that you can drink like a
fucking animal like I did and then take
75 days off or whatever,
and then you have a brand new liver.
I'm not a fucking dope.
I know that.
It's like I'd beat the shit out of
a car. All right? But you know what?
I didn't beat the shit
out of it and 75 days.
So rather than the fucking car
being 75 more days beat on it,
stopped at whatever fucking number
I beat on it. You know I get it.
Look, oh, you guys are, do
you know some of you guys?
What you're doing to me is the same
thing that they do to the Patriots.
You see me get into towards the
fucking brass ring of 162 pounds.
So now you starting to hate on me.
I get it.
You see me becoming a champion
right before your very ears on this
podcast. Actually, I got to tell you
this, I'm taking a loss this week.
I'm already calling it on
Thursday. There's no way I'm
getting down to one 62. Um,
I got busy this week and then also
I was just feeling it. My bones,
like I took a day off, then I go take
another day off, give you body arrest. Uh,
just try to eat as well as you can, which
I did. And then today I went to the gym.
Yeah.
Went down there and I trued
to fucking weights around,
did 45 minutes of cardio and I'm right
back on it, right back on it again.
Um,
so
okay.
Weighed my cell was like a buck 66
and change after the fucking workout.
So I think by Sunday I may be,
I can be like one 65, one 64,
so whatever, it's, what am I do
quick? Am I going to start crying,
like fucking gym or say and have rules
change. That one 64 now means one 62.
Now. I'm not, I'm a, I'm just now,
my goal is to get down to one
64 and then the week after
down to one 62 and then I did
it, you know, and then that's it.
I'll buy myself a little fucking
a championship ring instead of a,
a fucking smoking a cigar.
I'm going to have one of those cakes,
those lollipop cakes.
I didn't know what
those things are called,
but those things are the funniest God
damn thing ever to me. Cake on a stick.
You know what I mean?
Like that's one of those things
where you're just a fat fuck.
If you eat cake on a stick, you're a fat.
Fuck it. I don't want to hear like, Oh,
a lot smaller than it out that
will fucking slice of cake.
Who the fuck has a slice of cake
other than on their birthday?
You know what I mean?
Now you just add in fucking cake on a
stick cause you'd think it's smaller.
There's certain things that uh,
you know, I just don't have any,
I have zero tolerance for
cake on a stick donuts.
MMM.
Any of that shit that stuffed
with marshmallow was sugar
and it's like the color
of like those snowballs.
Does anybody eat those anymore?
I don't know who the fuck he those things.
But anyhow,
when you're just sitting there with a
sugary lump a shit, like I don't have any,
I don't have any sympathy for you.
What are you doing?
Um, so anyways, uh, oh,
what the fuck was I going to talk about
Becky? Brain up. Bill, where are you
talking about cake on a staff. It's gone.
It just like that. It's gone and there's
nothing we can do about it. Um, oh,
and also as far as my diet being
fucked, I'm going to try that. Uh,
yeah,
I'm going to try it. That, uh, that Sunday
gravy recipe. Then I was watching, uh,
like a bunch of fucking Italians making
the whole God damn it was just awesome.
So I'll let you guys know how that goes.
And I'm also fucking with my garage here.
Uh,
let me, let me read the, uh,
okay.
Let me read the advertising here. Jesus
Christ, the whole momentum of this podcast
fucking went down.
Here we go. Away we go. You know, it's
funny, I had no idea that that the,
the decision even got
reversed about Tom Brady. I,
I thought it was going to happen on
Friday so I wasn't even paying attention.
And then I got a bunch of text messages.
Congratulations.
I'm like about what people like what
do you live under? A fucking rock.
It's like not items. Just tell them,
put on the TV today. Sorry. All right.
Two attachments to reads everybody.
Can you deal with two reads?
MMM.
All right. There we go. What is
it doing here? What are you doing?
What are you doing? Come on. Sorry guys.
I usually have this ready.
You know,
I don't you fucking hate when somebody
just doesn't attach the fucking thing.
Why do I have to fucking downloading it?
Well,
I think they'll do something like a,
Hey, what time do I need to be there?
I have all the information in the attached
document and you've got to download
it for it to be,
say like seven 30
what is this
production node script for Ad Week of?
I can't read this shit.
Okay.
There's like riding on top of writing here
and for some reason they give me
their graphic to fucking download. I,
this is all going off the road that's
going off the fucking rails here.
All right. I'm going to try to read this,
but there's like words behind the words.
All right.
Okay.
I don't know what this is for.
I think it says Oxyo Reid,
R D. I don't even know what it says. This.
This shit in front of this yellow shit.
All right. It's okay. You can admit it.
The last thing anyone wants to do his
work after work is waiting in line at the
grocery store. Oh, this is blue apron.
Yeah.
Schlep home and cook a
complicated meal and expensive,
unhealthy takeout is hardly better.
That's where the new service,
blue apron comes in.
Blue Apron delivers farm fresh ingredients
and step by step recipes to your home,
allowing you to create healthy,
handcrafted meals at home without
going to the grocery store.
This is way better than those.
Those,
you know those fucking guys who drive
around in the cars with food and the back
seat. It's like, when
the hell was that cooked?
I've got a buddy of mine
that orders that shit. Yeah.
Yeah.
Guy Just you orders like a salmon dinner
and it shows up two minutes later.
It's like who cooked that and when?
How long has it been riding around and
somebody fucking car. I like blue apron.
They like sending you the ingredients.
This is just like something went
to the grocery store for you.
It's like you got a broad, your life
would, you don't have to pay up. Well,
I mean you do, but it's way
cheaper for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron sends you fresh ingredients,
perfectly proportioned, making,
cooking healthy meals, really
easy and fun. Oh Great.
No trips to the grocery store and
no waste from unused ingredients.
Plus you'll learn to cook with specialty
ingredients that are normally hard to
find.
Blue Apron is perfect for date night
cooking with friends and they even offer
friendly family fam plants,
friendly plants with kid
friendly ingredients so the
whole family can eat well
and have fun preparing the meals together.
God,
there's so much coffee
and I'm so fucking stupid.
Each balance meal is 500 to 700
calories per serving and it's so tasty.
You'd never know.
Cooking takes half an hour,
so does reading this copy you dumb as me.
Shipping is flexible and free
and the menus are always new.
They won't send the same meal twice.
Okay,
get the fuck Outta here.
If I order it every day for a year,
I'm not gonna get the same. What am I
eating? A squirrel by the end of the year,
they work around your schedule and
dietary preferences in Blue Apron.
Experts source only the best seasonal
ingredients for incredible meals like
Asian style pork burgers with
crunchy slaw. God Damn it.
That sounds good.
And flat.
Iron steaks with Romesco
sauce and roasted potatoes.
You'll cook incredible meals and be
blown away by the quality and freshness.
This is fucking unbelievable, man.
Blue Apron. It's a better way to cook.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first two meals for free by going to
blue apron.com/burr my tree.
Really the first two meals are on me.
When you go to blue apron.com/burr
blue apron.com/burr.
All right.
And I was told I had two copies.
Okay.
I only got one. That's all I got. I
don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Okay.
Where the hell's my fucking phone? I
was told that I had, did I shut it off?
Good. Gives a shit. All right.
Anyway, so let's plow ahead here. Um,
so I'm,
I'm
okay.
Finally like turning my attention
to my fucking piece of shit.
Goddamn cock sucking
motherfucking cunt of a garage.
I have the worst fucking garage.
I have a worst garage than somebody who
has no garage. That's how bad my garages.
Okay.
As I told you guys before,
the property line down my driveway,
like angles in at like a 30 degree angle.
My garage was built by two
different fucking people,
at least one person who added to the
front of it and built out the right side.
And on the left side when they went to
line up the right side with the left side,
whether we're going to
put the garage doors,
looked straight at Clorox and
realized that there was a tree there.
So rather than removing the tree
or backing up their fucking wall,
they just fucking said fuck it
and put the wall behind the tree.
So my garage doors are at
like a 15 degree angle,
which is an optical illusion as
I'm trying to back this trucking,
the doors have faced this way, the
garage, his face the other way.
And I got a wall that's closing
in 30 degrees on the right.
Okay.
Which is now my left
as I fucking look over.
It's a fucking disaster is what
I'm trying to say. So anyways,
I'm sitting there and I'm
trying to, uh, you know,
I'm into this grip strength workout.
So I have, I have a pull up,
okay.
A pull up bar, Chin up bar, dip
station, and it takes up a lot of space.
So I'm going to put that on craigslist.
I'm going to sell that thing and
I'm gonna get this pull up bar.
And just mounted to the wall.
Yeah.
All right.
Then my wife wanted a speed bag,
so I knew where I was going to put that.
I had two cabinets that were on the floor.
Those were going up on the walls.
And then I have two bikes,
one for me and the one that I
bought my wife that she never uses.
And I'm putting those on the
wall. All right. And then I,
I wanted to get a peg board.
Yeah.
All right.
So I get the peg board.
The only place I can mount it is at the
front of the garage where that guy put
that fucking Janky extension onto it
because there's enough head room for my
giant head if and when I'm ever strong
enough to get up to the top of it.
So the fucking pegboard is 36 by
36 I go down there to measure it.
Right. And wouldn't, you know,
35 fucking motherfucking cunt inches in.
Is this galvanize fucking useless as pipe.
So I'm like,
you fucking motherfucker.
So I call up
to come over.
Yeah.
[inaudible] fucking just hack it up
to shut off the water, hack it off,
and then cap it right inside the wall.
And he comes in and immediately he's like,
oh, that's galvanized pipe.
That's original to the house.
And back in the day, they used to just
thread those things right on the spot.
So the only way for me to take that
thing out was I'd have to go all the way
into the walls in your house,
in the ceiling all the way downstairs
that you just re did. I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me. You just
can't cut it off there. He's like, no,
I can't. I can't do that. I should
ask him if he could rethread it.
They're the old school way,
but I know they probably don't
make one of those anymore.
So he caps the fucking thing off
with this nipple sticking out,
which would then make the peg board
have to be off the wall just far enough
where if I went to open the garage door,
that swings in,
it would hit the fucking thing and
then I couldn't get my truck in.
So
I'm done fighting the garage.
I'm now going to try to find a peg board
that isn't 36 by 36 maybe they make one
that's just 24 did they make one that's
just 24 and I don't want those long
skinny ones because those things don't
fucking work because you need like a 200
foot fucking roof, whatever. I'll
look it up later. So anyways, um,
I have decided that I'm going
to stop fighting my garage.
I'm going to get a peg board that fits
there and even if I have to cut it in
half and fucking customized the thing,
it's what I'm going to do because I really
am fascinated with that grip strength
workouts.
And I like,
yeah,
I just like building up muscle like that.
It seems way more,
I dunno appliable to my life,
okay.
That I can fucking lift my,
my own body up to me is better
than trying to bench 200 pounds.
Like I like to try to do back in the day,
which I guess is great.
If a fucking rock fell on me, I could
get the goddamn thing off me or I guess,
but I think mostly, you know, like what,
say I ever got kidnapped by
that guy in silence of the lamb,
then he threw me down that fucking hole.
You know what I mean?
I would have enough fucking strength
that I could go horizontal, right.
And just walk my way right
out of that fucking thing.
Or at least to the top of the whole thing.
I mean,
he's got all the weapons and shit,
but uh, you know, that'd be funny.
You get up to top of the hole and you're
fucking gassed and he's just standing
there like, why is he such
running at you with a fucking ex?
Um, so anyway, so that
got me, you know, I was,
I was looking at pegboards on Youtube,
which then got me into, uh, you know,
those rock climbing gym. So
with all those, you know,
those cool holds in that type of stuff.
And I watched this one
woman in this German stunt,
a stunt man class,
just like,
she literally had like chimpanzee
strength. She was just flying,
which one of most amazing fucking
things I've ever seen. So anyways,
I ended up going to this,
uh,
this website called atomic
holds a t o m I k atomic holds.
And uh,
I'd love to reach out to these guys to
see if they'd advertise slash send me
some free fucking shit
is I redo my garage. Um,
and all I want to do is why
don't I saw this guy had,
was he just had a couple of two by fours
in the top of is a ceiling and then he
just had like some chains and then like
one of those c clamps that you could
just put all these different holds on.
They have like small bombs,
atomic bomb missile pipe bombs,
um,
and you just do like
pull ups on these things.
And then if you get a number of
them and he got a long board,
you can just put a run of
them together and, and,
and just sort of climb from one to the
other. It just seems fucking cool as shit.
It's a way better way to work your core
without having to get on the ground and
do those old school fucking ups.
So I think I'm going to do a,
okay,
I'm going to turn my garage.
I'm done fighting the fucking thing.
I'm done fighting it.
I'm just going to,
I'm going to work with the measurements
that I have and I'm going to put some,
uh, some of those climate holds up
there and some of those, uh, missiles,
pipe bombs of what they called it,
just different grips.
I'm going to have those hanging
from the fucking ceiling and a,
I'll have my pull up bar,
my wife will have the speed bag and uh,
that's good. And I'm going
to get, uh, I flat, uh,
found this great flooring from rubber
flooring inc I made like a grocery list.
I haven't ordered any of this shit yet,
but rubber flooring inc seem to have
like the best gym flooring that I could
find. And uh, and once again, I don't
know how I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
okay.
Cut that shit special when
it goes through Sunday.
I really should just take
a picture of my garage.
I'd just get weirded out showing
people the inside of my house,
even if he is the garage, if
he just fucking see the, uh,
uh, it's actually embarrassing. I mean,
part of me just wants to have it torn
down and rebuilt, but I know some,
it'd be like, yeah, I can
do that for about 160 grand.
Can you meet me in the middle?
Um,
but even then, even if they
were to rebuild it, oh, I'm,
I'm still dealing with the property line.
I'm still really limited with space. So,
uh, I think I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna fucking
okay.
I'm just going to work
with what the fuck I have.
I've done fight in the house the same
way we would done fight in the house when
it came to our stairs.
Uh,
let go from the upstairs to the downstairs
at my house was originally a ranch
and then they built the downstairs and
they blew out a closet and that's what
they sent this to the staircase through.
So the,
the opening is just a closet door opening.
So you can't get a couch down there.
You've got to bring it to the
outside of the fucking house.
It's just a big fucking pain in the
God damn ass is all I can tell you.
I've got to bring it
through my fucked up garage.
I got to literally care the
couch down the driveway,
through the garage into the backyard
and then up the stairs and just,
it's a fucking, it's
ridiculous. So anyways, um,
but I'm slowly but surely
fixing all of this shit,
but we just gave up on the stairs one
day. We just, we just like, you know what,
let's just stop fighting the stairs.
The stairs are the stairs. Fuck it.
So I think I might do that with the,
uh, the garage, you know what I mean?
The garage is the garage.
Fuck it.
And if I can hang a bunch of shit up
there and then not have to go to the gym
cause I got my own fucking gym and um,
you know,
and maybe just get one of those flat
benches and I think that's all I need.
Rubber flooring and then all the,
all the shit that I'm going to work out
with is going to be up off of the floor.
So in one corner I can have
all the original parts to
my truck that I had taken
off and then I'm just going to have the
gym. Uh, that's, that is my game plan.
That is my dream fucking
home gym there. So, uh,
but if you're thinking of doing
some shit like that, and you know,
if you're into American Ninja Warrior,
I am not like you're
going to compete in it,
but you just fascinated with how fucking
strong the men and women are on that
thing. Uh, atomic holds
is a great website,
um, to go check out.
And the guys, you know,
go on Youtube too,
if you just atomic holds and just look
at videos and this guys reviewing all the
different holds and that type of shit.
And they also kind of tell
you which ones are easy,
which ones are more difficult.
You get to see what they look like,
you learn the names of them, and then
just make a little grocery list, add a,
that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to try and put
this fucking thing together,
you know,
I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about.
And then he come absolutely shred. Um,
for one last time as I'm sliding into 50,
I'm gonna be one of those guys.
Like I'm going to start dressing like
Jack Lalaine if I actually get in shape,
you know that onesy Fonzie
fucking mechanic zip up.
Um, so anyways, if anybody's
done anything like that, uh,
got any of those atomic holds,
those things and can recommend
stuff for a beginner. Uh,
I just think that the, I think they're
fucking awesome and I've always,
I don't know why,
but that level of strength I've always
respected the most people can climb up a
fucking rope, the fucking pegboard and
all that shit. I think it's awesome.
So anyways, I hope that wasn't
too fucking boring for you.
I'll let you guys know how the
Sunday gravy goes on Monday and uh,
whatever. I think it's going to be
a great football season. I'm happy
ladies back.
I know that the lawsuit's going to
continue and all that type of shit and
Goodell's gonna, you know, appeal. It is
a lot of fucking big ego's going on here.
Who? Who's kidding who, but, um,
I'm glad it's over and colts fans.
I want you to know I'm
not shitting on you. Okay?
I'm not shitting on you guys and
I'm not shitting on your players.
I'm just shitting on Jim
or say, okay. And, uh,
I don't think that we're
any better than that guy is.
I'm just sick of the fucking accusations.
Only going one way.
You know what I mean?
We've only came at you one time for
pumping crowd noise in. That was it.
We didn't say shit about all the other
stuff that I've said 9,000 times on it.
So having said all that,
um,
I don't think the AFC east
is going to be a cake walk.
I think the bills are going
to be really fucking good. Um,
I think rex Ryan is great when he's got
a great defense and he has a fucking, uh,
you know, somebody quarterback, they can
just manage the game he's shown before.
You know, he did that with the jets and
they beat us in the playoffs at home.
Kicked our fucking asses. So I'm going to
pull a Bella check here, you know, hello.
That's take anybody lightly. He'll
the yes, but, um, and finally, oh,
I gotta I gotta give it a
little law shadow to the
Toronto Blue Jays. I'm sorry,
I wouldn't bring in new guys up.
You guys are fucking, uh, you know,
I can't say you're walking
away with the Goddamn, uh,
a l lease, but I, yeah, good on you guys.
You know, you have a one in a while. 93,
God knows the fuck and you can't
depend on your maple leafs.
Maybe you get a world series out of it.
Um,
but I'm looking forward to that type of
shit. All went today. Hail to the victors.
Value in Hail to the
victors. Fuck, get jam.
Haba is taken over. Go
Fuck Yourself. Big 10. Um,
having said that,
I think it's going to take them at least
two years to turn the thing around, um,
substantially. But uh, you know, you
know, they get nervous. You know,
they get nervous in Ohio state down there
in Columbus, you know, they get nervous.
They are, who gives a
fuck? You won it last year.
Have you guys end up
going to the fucking NFL?
And even if they don't that
second half wield this year,
it's the hardest fucking thing in
the world is to continue trying to be
successful I think at the college level
coaching because especially college, who?
Jesus Christ, you get a guy for
one year now if he's any good. Um,
but whatever, as always, I don't
know shit about what I'm talking.
[inaudible] Bob, thank
you for listening. And uh,
I'm going to go smoke a fucking scoby and
watched this game. Can't fucking wait.
That's it.
Have a great weekend.
Oh my God.
That fucking line dancing.
Can there be a mass suicide
amongst the line dancers?
Could that just fucking happen in the
middle of one of your fucking corn ball?
Stupid ass fucking sell country
music is country music is,
I don't even know what it's for.
It's for like pod people.
There's absolutely no soul in it.
What's so it there? Is it all right?
They're angry.
Redneck listening to this punching the
dashboard or your Chevy s 10 all right.
There isn't it fucking sucks.
And that line dancing,
we sit there with your fucking thumbs
in your book and pockets and you do that
little I'm doing, I'm, I'm actually,
I'm in Dallas, Texas this week.
So let's just go for big error in this
one. We do that then you're fucking,
I wish, I wish this was a vodcast,
which I'm not doing by the way.
So stop fucking asking me.
The great thing about this thing is
you can listen to it while you're doing
other shit. Right? All right. So anyways,
they do that stupid thing where they
banned their fucking knees and the,
and I can't even think of the
fucking music [inaudible] is none.
Other music goes and,
and then they do that little thing
where they just one of their,
one of their feet, right? The right
foot. We'll say the right foot.
It's just pivoting on the heel and the
toes face forward and then to the side
and then back to the front.
Ah.
Then they do that little thing where
they bring their fucking foot up and they
spanked the bottom of their foot.
All of them,
you don't kills me about those people
is they actually think that Jesus loves
them. I got news for you. Rednecks.
Jesus is looking the other way.
He's embarrassed.
He's combing his fucking hair to his face
when he watches you. People lie. Debts.
He has
looking like that chicken,
the rent money.
He's got a little gold watch.
Oh, I don't want, I'm going to talk
about fuck his bike newspaper here.
This is at the risk of burning
some potential material.
This is stuff that you could look
forward to watching me go off on in the
future. On stage. All
right. Hang on a second.
I got blow my God damn nose
again. Hold on. Hold on.
Okay,
let's go eat a pastry.
Ah,
fuck.
Wow. Yeah, we go. You had to
get it out of the mustache.
Anyways, so everybody saw what happened.
On a swatch Nigga this week, right?
So Time magazine has a uh,
yeah.
Has An article out there
says sex lies arrogance.
What makes powerful men act like pigs?
Okay,
so
I look at who wrote it.
It's written by Old Lady.
How fucking funny is that?
Okay.
Sex lies. Arrogance. What Po? What
makes powerful men act like pigs?
A woman is going to tell the world
why guys act the way they act.
Do you realize how fucked up?
Yeah.
At what point are men get to make a
fucking stand here with this. Okay.
I don't want to come off like a chauvinist
pig here and you just giving away.
Every a guy should have
wrote this article.
He could've had so much more fucking
insight. What the fuck does a woman know?
She doesn't know. And the
whole thing, it's just a thick,
the whole thing is written.
But in the,
in the,
the female's point of view,
which is the only thing you understand
is being that woman who got cheated on.
Yeah.
So there's this woman's scorn
vibe under the whole article,
but there's no information in here.
I learned nothing. I was really good.
I learned nothing as a guy and she's
fucking wrong on most of her points.
One of the great things they like
to say is that a men of power,
the reason why they cheat is
because they feel entitled.
They feel they're entitled.
I'm not going to burn the bit,
but that is so that's so not even true
and what kills me is some fucking broad
like this. Nancy Gibbs would
sit there and argue with me
being a lady, a lady. Do you
understand what you're doing there?
You're basically telling me that you
know how my brain works better than I do.
I was watching her with the reason why I
bought this fucking article cause I was
sitting,
I was watching it on television.
I saw the art and the obviously like
a fucking magnet. I'm drawn to this.
I'm like, Oh, I like this topic.
I want to hear about this.
And then Nancy Gibbs comes
on and she's talking to a guy
hit. He's going really? Oh is
as long as I was. Okay. Like
it's at Chateau. It's just, it's
fucking terrific. That would be like me.
Like here's something for
you. His is like, like women.
You never get to know what it's like
to have a dick. All right, so stop it.
Stop trying to write articles.
Try,
stop trying to act like you're in our
heads and you know what we're thinking.
You don't. You're always going to be
observed. You're going to be an observer.
You sitting on the grassy knoll what
to do? Where did the shots come from?
You have no fucking idea.
You just coming up with your theories,
the nerve of you to get
to cover. If fucking Time
magazine with this horse shit.
Just a bunch of horse shit. They got
one over there. Listen to this shit. Uh,
the turning points,
this is from another lay.
They had two people write about this shit.
Elaine,
I can't even read a fucking last name
as CEO, Lino, whatever Frances having,
it's Anita Hill moment.
When the law professor testified before
the Senate committee in 1991 that a
former boss, Clarence Thomas,
had sexually harassed her.
He denied everything and was
elevated to the Supreme Court.
Notice how the fucking angry cunt leaves
out the fact that he was acquitted,
the guy was acquitted.
She makes it seem like he was accused of
that stuff and because of that he would
because of that attention,
he, he was elevated to the
Supreme Court. But anyways,
hearings were attorney,
but hearings were terming point.
Women suddenly said that the mad men
style of behavior they had been putting up
with at work for so long, the
leering, the inappropriate touching,
the sexual banter was not acceptable.
Do you understand that?
She's not talking about the 1960s there.
She's talking about 1991 I'm not
saying that that shit wasn't happening,
but you know, I was in the
workforce. They're all right.
People weren't walking around going,
hey,
touch grabbing people's asses at
work in 98919901991 they weren't,
I mean,
generally speaking weren't,
but this lady just fucking
goes the mad men style,
which is from the 1960s Madison Avenue.
Hey Sweetie,
go make me a fucking sandwich.
That error completely ignoring all
the bullshit that happened in the late
sixties seventies right through the
fucking eighties and the 80s they were
talking about women wearing their fucking
little power suits and power ties and
all that fucking horse shit.
This is all just one of these classic
things where you just, you just,
you have your angle and then you just,
you just write the whole fucking article.
It's complete horse shit. Um, what
the hell is the quote in here?
I wanted to read. I don't
even know. All right,
let me tell you something Nancy,
let me tell you something, Elaine.
Those guys don't do that shit cause
they feel entitled. They don't.
All right,
they don't.
And if you want to know why come out to
a comedy club cause I'm not burden the
fucking material.
I'll talk about it a little bit.
I'll talk about real quick.
Alright.
What it is is women don't understand
what it's like to have a dick.
They just don't get it.
Okay.
The fucking thing tells us what to do.
You know now,
right now they're rolling
their eyes because they don't
understand the sex drive
that we have. How could they?
They got a badge. All right,
and the thing is,
there's no information out there to
help people to help guys out. Nothing.
All guys get, there's no information
about being a guy in general. Hey,
keep it in your pants. That's the sexual
advice we get. That's what we get.
Fucking you got Kosmal.
There's reams of shit talking
about all the folds in your vagina.
Every goddamn month we get,
Hey, keep it in your pants.
That's the kind of advice guys get. You
go to jail. Hey, don't drop the soap.
That's it.
That's all you get.
We get little fucking four sentences
and that's how we're supposed to fucking
navigate through life.
So you're pulling with a deck,
you've got this ridiculous
fucking sex drive.
The only thing that fucking keeps it in
check is the fact that women won't fuck
you. You got to figure out,
you got to talk them into it.
You go through dry spells.
That's the only thing that prevents a
guy from fucking 24 hours a day is other
women making it difficult
for us to get laid.
But then what happens is when you
become an a position of power,
these cunts flip the fucking table and
will suck your Dick under your fucking
God damn desk while your
wife's sits across from you.
So now the governor has taken off.
You've never had to control your sexual
urges because it was always done for you.
You like a spoiled kid.
Now you're fucking famous.
You got all these broads coming at you.
You don't know what to do
because you never really noticed how
much you've been been led around by your
Dick. Now, I'm not saying every
powerful guy out there is an angel.
There's not this definitely some pigs
out that there's definitely some guys out
there who do feel entitled.
But to just paint it with that broad
fucking stroke of a brush and have a
fucking woman sitting
there telling me it's you.
You don't know what you
talking about, lady. All right,
you have to just fucking blows my mind
blows my fucking that they put two people
on this assignment and
they were both women.
Was that some political
correct fucking thing?
Cause they were worried that guys we're
going to say what the fuck I'm saying
that basically their husbands would be
out fucking everything that moved if
women wanted to fuck
the way we want it to.
I don't know.
And not to mention most people can
handle power and that includes broads.
Okay,
so you get some guy in a powerful position
is ego's already going to go through
the fucking roof and then you combine
that with the fact that basically half of
the free world will now fuck him.
Any supposed to somehow rein that in and
is only piece of advice is keep it in
your pants, you know? I mean I dunno
did I, that gets really embarrassing
the Time magazine. What?
This fucking superficial
that they just basically
they too. I mean, it was like psych 101
how they broke it down,
even though shit on,
on a Arnold Schwarzenegger about how he,
he likes fucking around with girls
that aren't beautiful. You know,
they said it was because he was
intimidated by beautiful women and
Blahblahblahblahblah see,
they're women. They don't,
they don't get the difference between
hooking up with the hottie and hooking up
with the plain Jane girl who's
going to try harder, okay.
As opposed to the fucking chick who's,
who's got 0% body fat and just
thinks she's God's God damn gift.
You've seen that, right? You go to a
titty bar, the hottest one there does,
she tries hard is that fucking
one in the middle? She doesn't.
And after a while, you know what? You
start looking at those hotties going,
you know what? They're fucking more
trouble than they're worth. All right,
I'll wipe my dick sucked to completion.
Who am I going with?
The supermodel looking chick? Oh, that
chick who's just happy to be there.
Anyway, so I got it. I got sick.
Yeah. I, it's like, all right,
so I'm thinking, all right,
that means I got to get up at fucking
five 30 return the rental car and all that
horse shit. Why don't I stay at a
hotel right next to the airport?
So my travel agent gives
me the whole list of, uh,
of options of where I can stay. So I'm
like, yeah, fine. Fuck it. All right.
I check them out. And one of them is
the Sheridan Sheridan, respected name,
a very quality hotel. I say,
I'm going to stay there.
And the price reflected that it was a
quality hotel. It costs me like, oh,
you know, 180 bucks or something like
that was a lot of fucking money. So, uh,
[inaudible] 99, something like
that, you know, for Philly,
that's a lot of fucking money considering
I was right outside upper Darby.
So anyways,
here's my travel tip for you.
Do not ever stay at the fucking Sheridan
at the Philadelphia International
Airport. It is a beyond
ghetto, Sheridan and I,
and it's so fucking ghetto that I,
I knew it was a fucked up Sheridan
before I even went into it.
I pulled up and it looked fine. I
got out of my car, it looked fine,
and as I walked into the place,
as I was walking in,
these four chicks were coming out and
they just look like horse from a reality
show,
awful tattoos on their feet.
Tidies up and pushed together these cheap
ass looking stripper shoes. And I went,
oh no. Oh No, not, not, not, not
a bad hotel. Please God, please.
I start praying to the travel
gods, please, please don't
let this be a bad hotel.
You know, I'm like way, but you know,
at first I was like, all right, what,
what are these like call girls?
Did you just get done servicing some
fucking married business guy on the road?
Show what they did, but it was like
12 noon. It's like, no, no, no.
Call Girls are up at 12 noon. All right.
They already wiped fucking washed off.
The vaginas hosed him down
at like eight in the morning.
And now they just fell asleep face down
in a fucking pile of glitter and they're
not going to wake up against it like five
in the afternoon. That's how it works.
And they wake up, they fucking, you
know, I dunno what they do. You know,
they put some fucking vitamin E on the,
on the ligature marks around
the neck from the night before.
Do you know,
you know what's fucked up about ligature?
Nobody ever uses that statement unless
somebody's got choked to death, you know,
ligature, my, no, it does never any
ligature marks because you know why?
Because these girls who
are into that type of shit,
if they survive the encounter, they
fucking, they were that little, uh,
that little ass got the next day around
that neck. You know, the hoary one,
a choker.
That's what they were to cover it up.
You have to have a girl wants
you to do that once you a choker.
I remember one time I was with
this girl, right? And she, uh,
she will all this type of shit.
She wanted me to slap her in the face and
all this, all this crazy shit that, uh,
that all these fucking women
shows they never address.
They never addressed the amount
of fucking women that liked that.
They like it rough.
It's fucking insane.
Unless I just keep picking the same kinds
of fucking women, but it's ridiculous.
The amount of fucking Bra that
I've gone out with, you know,
fucking women's Lib, fucking Blah,
blah, blah. My career comes first.
If we get married, I'm not taking your
last name, Yadda Yadda, fucking Yada,
right?
Then you get them in, you
know, the fucking all pro
women. There's pro women that,
and I'm making my own money and fucking,
you know,
in a couple of other fucking lyrics
from some stupid Beyonce song, right?
All that fucking horse shit.
You're going to respect me eyeball
to eyeball the images of women on TV,
all that fucking horse shit.
And then you get them back to
your place and lo and behold,
they have a rape fantasy. You know, am
I the only guy by the only fucking guy.
So anyways, so I see these
fucking deceased, these hordes.
Father didn't stick around,
you know, George Foreman Grill.
Eaton fucking just,
just never had a chance
for girls just coming out.
Just never had a fucking chance.
And you know,
just dressed like fucking truck stock,
fucking whores.
And the sad thing is,
is they think they look good and they
don't even realize the vibe that they're
putting out. They don't know any better.
They don't fucking know any better.
All right? There was a rusted out
car in their front yard that day.
They were born and they never
had a fucking chance. You know,
the only fucking male voice that was in
their household when they was growing up
was the Billy Best that the deaf,
they're fucking dead left behind.
You know what I mean? Just, they
just never had a fucking chance.
So that was my first red flag
and I was gone off. God, maybe.
Maybe they use some sky miles.
Is that how they got in here?
And I just walked into the
second I walked in. I just,
I just tell the caliber of human being
that was in there straight across the
board here. Alright. The
caliber or white person,
the caliber of black person,
the caliber of fucking male female,
you just can tell.
You know what I mean?
Saw some black dude,
you know when they get their hair braided
but they don't have enough money to
fucking get it braided enough so they got
all those little hairs sticking out of
it, you know, cause he can't see the
scalp in between the braids. You know,
it's not looking fucking right.
It's just not looking right.
The fucking white dude with
the chief Anderson little suit,
the fucking creased up Brown loafers
with this gold lamay horse shit on the
front of it.
You know,
shoes look like they cost 11 bucks and
I'm just going out and now God least let
the fucking room be clean, you know? So
I check and the lady behind the counter,
she was nice enough,
you know,
I don't know how she ended
up at this fucking Sheridan.
Maybe she has stepped out of line
at the big a stockholders meeting.
This is, this is, they're
stitched Sheridan Siberia.
So then I go up to my room and uh,
it's weird. It had like one of the,
it's almost looked like a little house.
You come walking in,
there's a door and right next to it
there's this big window for some stupid
fucking reason.
If I want to overlook half the elevators
in the fucking poor excuse for a pool
that they had, so the blinds
would were down. All right.
So I open it up and it's a sweet,
I'm like Nice. It was a nice room.
It wasn't bad at all.
So I'm in there for like five fucking
minutes and I hear this knock on the door,
right? Guy fucking knocks on the
door. It was covered in foam.
So that's what it sounded like.
And I opened the door,
there's a guy standing there with this
giant coffee table and he goes and he's
trying to walk in with this giant
cocktail. I'm like, Whoa, whoa. I go,
you got the wrong room. I didn't
order a table. He goes, not all this,
this tables is your, your,
your room's missing a table.
Like it is. They go, yeah. Yeah. The last
people who are here broke the other table.
I was like, Jesus Christ, what? They have
like a party or something. Anyway, yeah,
I thought he was going to say
no. He went like, yeah and I go,
well did they fucking feel
they get the place now?
I think everything's been just dawn.
I mean,
you know I'm laying in fucking angel
dust and cocaine and shit. You know,
he keeps getting worse that I'm sitting
there for another couple of minutes and
then I just hear this lady
telling this story. Right.
Mother fucker
tell me that mother fucker can't
come up with a motherfucker.
And I'm like,
is that it leaves it at least a guest is
that at least the guests and I fucking
opened the blinds to my window and she's
one of the people cleaning the rooms.
Just cursing up a fucking
store loud as fucking hell.
Okay.
Like all broke.
He broke people are the loudest fucking
people because they live near the
freeways. They lived near the subway.
They used to shouting over shit.
So she's out there. This mother fucker
trying to tell me what time it is paid.
Right.
And just screaming
and you know how much I curse.
Okay.
Okay. I was offended and you know
how much I curse. I was just like,
Jesus Christ, can you please,
I might have kids someday.
Can you please stop Carsten like that.
But I didn't say shit cause I,
I mean at that point I knew it. What was
going to happen? I would have been like,
oh, it just would've been like,
excuse me, could you do me a favor?
Could you use now?
Ain't nobody talking to you baby.
Right.
I didn't want to go through that whole
fucking thing at her screaming at me.
Plus she was so fucking big. She
probably could've just choke, slammed me.
And we would have had to have
a new fucking table in my room,
third fucking table that week.
And I'm a conservationalist.
Is that the right word? So, oh my God,
fuck it. Whatever. So I don't say shit.
So anyway,
so I dropped you off at Darwin.
It was just unbelievably depressing
that people have to live that way.
Fellow Americans have to live that
way and that we're always sitting here
fucking acting like we give a shit about
other countries and we need to help out.
We don't, all right, well we,
I mean you give a shit or I give a shit,
but our government doesn't,
we're working our way in
there to help them out.
Air quotes so we can take their natural
resources. All right. That's how it is.
That's what the fuck is really going
on. If you ever wondered why, all right,
they don't give a fuck about upper Darby,
new New Orleans or whatever. Fuck it.
All those blue collar towns that
are failing out there in Ohio,
they don't give a shit about
them cause they already own them.
So if there's any oil to be had,
they can just go in and
suck it out of the ground
that it didn't make any fucking sense.
So anyway,
so I go back to my ghetto ass
fucking Sheridan. Alright.
I come walking in there and uh,
if this point,
it's one in the morning.
Now,
if it was one in the morning
and I was at a nice hotel,
there'd be the usual thing. There would
be some people hanging down at the bar,
you know, drinking, getting
ready to cheat on their spouses.
Dress nicely though.
All right.
But because it was a
ghetto fucking Sheridan,
I went down there and most of the people
in the lobby where children running
around screaming like one in the morning,
kids just running around.
I felt like I was in
fucking Atlantic city.
You know those gamblers
degenerate gamblers,
they don't fucking handle
their kids. Right, right.
So just as see a fucking children. I
mean, I was waiting for fucking, you know,
Yohei was missing with somebody there,
you know, gathering them like you could,
you could've had a children's choir.
That's how many fucking kids were there.
So I could go up the elevator and I,
and I get out,
get out of the elevator and I walked
back up to my little, you know,
I told you the front of the room looked
like a house and there was a door.
And then there's the window.
And as I'm looking,
I'm at the door as I'm looking
down to take out my hotel key.
I looked down and on the window sill
is a three quarter eaten chicken wing
sitting on the fucking window sill.
I got pictures to prove it.
They're all going to be up on the
[inaudible] pot. Mm. podcast.com.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Is that the name of the website?
You know the name of the fucking website?
The Hell's wrong with me? Yeah, the MM.
The MM podcast.com. Uh, if you go up
there, I'll have all these pictures,
the pictures of, uh, the
tower theater and all that.
I didn't take any pictures when I was
driving through upper Darby could for
obvious fucking reasons. I didn't
want to be, you know, I just,
I would not want to be taking pictures
down there cause people either think
you're a cop or you're just at a
documentary. They're level of poverty,
which would be fucking in knowing to me
if I was in that situation. So anyways,
with that, that was my, Oh, and then
the next morning I woke up and uh,
I,
I dropped my car off it budget.
It was fucking hilarious
when these hilarious racial
moments here is I go to get
on the bus, the bus drivers,
black five white guys get on it.
He asked us where we're going, I got
US air. This guy says this and blah,
blah blah.
So we're driving in that
and he's listening to this
preacher because it's Sunday
morning and the guy, you know,
he's talking about, you know,
people need to be in to Jesus and
blah, blah, blah, all this, you know,
regular Jesus Shit,
right?
But then all of a sudden he starts
talking about Obama and around he's just
starts kind of trashing white people
just go.
And we should be giving thanks to Jesus
that a strong black man is president.
It's not afraid to stand up to the white
supremacy that we run in this country
and he's got it cracked.
And I'm sitting there fucking and all.
I did just cause I
wanted to have the laugh.
I just turned around and looked at
all the other four white guys and then
everybody is just sort of sitting down
looking at that wing tips like rarely.
What exactly is the call here? Or
can we say something? You know,
excuse me, we're not all
white supremacy. You know,
like what exactly is the proper response
to that? Because I thought it was,
I don't know. I actually thought
it was fucking hilarious.
I wish I could remember what the guy's
saying. Ah, Jesus. Now I'm fucking bomb.
And again on this fucking podcast
dress.
Okay.
Somebody who wants to fill my girlfriend.
It's like a centerfold.
Good for you. She's blonde.
She has a beautiful face,
a tiny waist and giant cans.
I have outdone myself. What? What the
fuck man, don't you sell yourself short?
Maybe you, maybe you're a, you're
a stud. So he says, however,
having a girlfriend of such
caliber as you might imagine,
comes with its share of problems.
Genes is, here we go. Like,
uh, like your good self.
I battle my battle,
keeping my temper under control at
times and particularly struggle when my
girlfriend and I go out in
public together. In short,
the amount of male attention
she gets is ridiculous.
And if times it's infuriating.
Have you ever found you found yourself
out with a girl and notice that every man
within a three mile radius from the
sweaty 22 year old walking boner to the
porky,
sexually frustrated father of three is
blatantly staring at her tits in her ass?
Um, I've always been of the opinion
that if a girl is obviously with a guy,
whether you know him or not,
it's a gentleman's code not to have a
staring contest with there with her,
with her a ring piece.
I don't know what that means.
What's that looking at her pussy. I have
no idea. This guys from Australia, um,
if a girl there's a loan
or with girlfriends, sure
objectify the shit out of her.
But I think if a girl is holding hands
with your boyfriend and you make it
obvious that your helmet is pressing
against the inside of your front Zipper,
then you're a cunt. Um, nothing
serious has happened yet,
but the weather is getting warmer.
The outfits are getting smaller and I'm
concerned I'm going to wind up with,
I'm going to wind up with perverts blood
and quite possibly come on my hands all
for now. Um, all right.
Okay.
All right. This is a tricky
situation. She's are, you know,
is a very tricky situation.
You know,
there's a price you pay for everything.
All right?
You're the one who has a
centerfold fucking girlfriend
with a great ass and Nice
set of fucking tits and a,
you just, you just have to,
okay,
this, this, this is, this
is how I look at this shit.
As long as you're a woman isn't going
around trying to get attention if she's
just fucking standing there and she's
so goddamn stunning that men are looking
at her, but you know, she's not, Ooh,
I dropped my lipstick and then slowly
bending over at the waist while looking
over her shoulder. Um,
if she's doing that,
I can tell you right now a bang or
another couple of times and then fucking
dumper because she's going to be an
absolute fucking nightmare. And a,
you don't need that in your life,
okay.
But if she's just a
stunningly gorgeous woman, um,
you, that kind of comes with it. And, uh,
if you lose your fucking temper
and you start acting like a maniac,
that's a great way to eventually
annoy the shit out of her.
And because she can't help
it. Like I said, if she's
not trying to get attention,
she can't help it, that
she's gorgeous. And uh,
if you then,
it's in this weird way,
you're giving her shit for being herself,
which is not fun for anybody and then
you're going to have a problem. So,
okay.
Um, I don't know how to, if you
know what it's like, it's like a,
it's like when I whore myself out at
the end of my shows and I sell DVDs.
All right.
I don't have to do that,
but I choose to do it and I'm
standing as a choice. I fucking made.
And then I stand there and what's
going to happen? I answered this. Yeah.
This is one of these podcast questions.
Alright?
Eventually somebody is going to come up
and they're going to fucking insult me.
He's tell me they didn't
like my act. Tell me. Uh,
they didn't think I was as funny as
when he saw me on TV and I can't get mad
because it's my fucking fault for
standing there like an asshole.
Just, you know, I, I put myself on the
Dunkin store and I got to admit, sir, if,
if you're, if this, if your girl is
the way that you've described her,
you just have to accept that it's,
it's par for the course and, uh,
just give yourself a little halftime
speech before you go out. You know,
I'm not going to lose my shit. Um, but
if it is overt,
uh,
there has to be a way that you can fucking
address it without pissing her off,
without, you know, you also don't
want to get into a fucking fight. Um,
I dunno. Just say, hey buddy can,
can you limit it to like know five
second shifts of staring at her tea?
I can't say tits.
Uh,
I don't know what you do.
Do that. That's a rough one.
That's a rough run. They, man,
that takes me back to being a,
okay
Jesus Christ. I was like 21
years old. I went on this,
I went out on a date with this girl who
was well out of my fucking league just
because I didn't have the
confidence to fucking be with her,
you know what I mean? Um, beautiful girl.
And I went out with her and I noticed he
just kept looking around the restaurant
to see who was looking at her and I
remembered it annoyed the shit out of me,
but I, I, I didn't have any
experience with beautiful women,
so I just sort of accepted it. And um,
but I never went out with her again.
It just, it drove it. I stopped, I tapped
out somewhere through the fucking dinner.
Even back then, I was an angry
son of a bitch. I was like,
let me get this straight.
I'm buying you fucking dinner and
you're looking around to see who's Elsa
staring at your tits.
Um, yeah, you're a cunt.
Good looking cunt. But uh, nonetheless,
someday those looks are going to be gone.
And I'm just going to
be left with the cunt.
You know who's going to be a psycho cunt
because you're an attention whore and
when the attention goes away,
you're going to be like some celebrity
who fell off the fucking man.
Fuck this bitch. Fuck this. Know.
And that was the other big shows
she does.
She gets what she wants.
She puts the rest on a
tray and the zip blah
in the freezer.
He doesn't care.
Does
make
money.
He's gone a little gold watch.
She's
dressed mouse on his.